[Musique]
pour communiquer travailler vous
informer vous l'utilisez tous les jours
mais savez-vous comment fonctionne
Internet dans ce grand angle on va
entrer dans les coulisses du réseau des
réseaux et pour commencer nous sommes
avec Nicolas Guillaume Nicolas Guillaume
bonjour expliquez-nous sous nos pieds en
fait se trouve un réseau Internet et
bien vous le savez pas mais voilà
pendant qu'on se parle et bien il y a
des données d'un très très grand
opérateur qui passe sous nos pieds sous
cette véloroute et qui permettent de
transporter vos photos vos vidéos vos
contenus parfois vos applications
d'entreprise d'une ville à une autre
jusqu'au cœur de réseau Internet
généralement c'est à Paris à Marseille
et bien ça passe ici le long des voies
de transport parfois le long des lignes
SNCF également le long des autoroutes en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelle justement
les autoroutes numériques et vous vous
êtes un opérateur régional privé dédié
aux entreprises et vous avez créé
justement une autoroute du numérique une
autoroute que vous avez cofinancé entre
Besançon et l'Alsace oui en fait nous
néalis on a un plus petit opérateur que
les grands opérateurs nationaux mais on
a besoin de transporter des grosses
capacités de bande passante entre les
villes c'est pour ça qu'on a créé notre
propre câble de monbellliard à
Strasbourg 260 km avec parfois
d'importants travaux de génie civil oui
alors paradoxalement on utilise des
infrastructures existantes les tubes qui
sont dans le sol qu'on appelle des
fouraux mais on a aussi de temps en
temps du cré avec des trancheuses des
gros appareils bien nos propres
tranchées pour déployer ces fameux
fourau quand il n'existait pas ça nous
permet d'avoir un câble le plus court
possible entre les villes pour justement
apporter ces ces flux dans des bonnes
conditions mais quel est l'intérêt s'il
existe déjà des autoroutes du numérique
de créer une deuxième ou une autre un
autre réseau et bien quand vous êtes
victime par exemple d'un acte de
malveillance ça nous est arrivé le 27
avril 2022 avec d'autres grands
opérateurs et bien ça permet de faire
circuler les flux sur plusieurs
autoroutes numériques ici sur ce capâ
s'il est coupé peut-être que les flux
vont passer à côté de nous sur le cap
qui passe long de la ligne SNCF par
exemple vous opérateurs vous proposez à
vos clients les entreprises on propose à
nos clients des entreprises et
desintitutions publiques de transiter
par ces câes alors parfois ils ne savent
pas tout simplement parce que ces flux
sont acheminés par différents chemins de
fibre optique et puis on va jusqu'à des
Data Center c'est les endroits où en
fait atterrissent ces fibres optiques et
ça permet donc de transporter ces
données de façon sécurisée jusqu'à des
endroits précisément très
sécurisés
alors on pénètre ici dans le data center
de besonon qui est en périphérie de la
ville oui bienvenue chez Euclide c'est
un lieu sécurisé exactement c'est un
c'est un lieu hyper sécurisé hyper
sécurisé avec différents points de
contrôle pour pouvoir accéder aux
équipements informatiques et un site qui
est également sous vidéosurveillance
permanente et finalement à quoi sert un
data center on peut parler d'un c'est un
un coffre fort numérique c'est un
endroit où vont être hébergé des
infrastructures informatiques et donc
des données numériques qui vont
transiter par le réseau Internet
jusqu'ici tout à fait pour être hébergé
en fait physiquement localement dans ces
murs c'est ça un data center c'est de
l'hébergement
physique alors là Karine on a changé
d'ambiance Sonor tout à fait on a changé
de décor aussi vous êtes ici au cœur
d'un data center autour de nous on a
plusieurs centaines de mètres carrés de
serveur informatique c'est ça d'armoir
informatique exement des armoires que
nous on appelle desbai donc vous en avez
sur l'ensemble du data center il y en a
à peu près 80 sur le site de Besançon et
c'est ici que sont stocké des données
qu'on va avoir des données qui vont
concerner la sécurité la santé le
transport l'éducation et cetera qui sont
vos clients ça ça commence par la PME
émergente jusqu'à là le grand groupe
industriel international en passant par
une une association ou une collectivité
locale et territoriale et vous leur
assurez à la fois une sécurité une
continuité d'hébergement c'est-à-dire
qu'ici il peut pas y avoir de coupure
électrique ou de panne tout à fait dans
un data center vous avez une activité 24
heur sur 24 et une redondance qui permet
un fonctionnement continu sur les
systèmes de refroidissement sur les
systèmes électriques et sur la
connectivité on imagine c'est très
énergivore et il y a des projections qui
disent que d'ici 2030 les datas seront
responsables de 13 % de la consommation
électrique mondiale alors comment on
fait pour maîtriser son impact on est
certifié dans tous nos data center ISO
500001 qui est donc une certification
sur la consommation d'énergie maîtrisée
et parmi vos clients et bien il y a la
collectivité grand Besin son métropole
on va justement aller les
[Musique]
retrouver donc là si on ouvre une
armoire ici par exemple
celle-ci alors là on un ensemble de
serveurs d'équipement réseau et puis des
disque pour stocker l'ensemble des
données qui servent à fournir tous les
services offerts par la collectivité
alors c'est vrai qu'on voit le site
Internet de la Ville et du grand
bedançon mais aussi tous les services
pour la population donc la gestion de
l'état civil l'eau l'assaainissement les
l'éducation et beaucoup d'autres quel
est l'intérêt d'héberger vos vos données
localement
nos administrés sont majoritairement
localisés sur la ville de bedançan et
puis la communauté urbaine donc
effectivement il y a pas trop de logique
à faire transiter des données à des
milliers de kilomètres donc autant les
localiser sur place ici on est dans un
dataenture qui est mutualisé avec
d'autres collectivité d'autres
entreprises qui ont aussi hébergé leurs
données donc on bénéficie d'une
infrastructure où on a une sécurité en
terme de d'énergie de gestion de la
climatisation on parle beaucoup de
cybersécurité mais ça fait aussi partie
la sécurité d'avoir un lieu où on a une
sorte de continuité de l'activité s'il y
a une coupure de courant s'il y a une
intrusion on sait qu'on est protégé
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de cette
émission j'espère que vous avez un peu
mieux compris comment est construit le
réseau Internet à
[Musique]
bientôt